[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm Kim PhD here and
I'm at the Sony booth at CES 2014 with
the Sony Xperia z1s
in the Xperia z1 compact so the Xperia
z1s is only a slightly different from
from the Xperia z1 so basically the z1
was never really an American phone on an
American carrier so they brought it to
the United States and is a t-mobile
exclusive for the z1 s the only thing we
have changed to make it a different
phone is it has 32 gigs of storage by
default now that's the stock default and
it has a couple of other little software
tweaks they have some new camera
features and you can check those out but
if you want to see essentially what the
z1 s looks like watch the Xperia z1
review because it's almost the same
phone the Xperia z1 compact on the other
hand is actually a slightly interesting
take a lot of people have been asking
for a high-end flagship phone
that's not huge and this is kind of what
you're looking at here so it's a 4.3
inch display might not be the super
compact that the iPhone is but you're
getting all the same high-end specs from
the Xperia Z in a compact body
so really the Xperia z1 compact is
exactly that it's the Xperia z1 compact
it has the same great operating system
the same Sony skin a lot of the same
waterproof feature is the same camera as
it's almost the exact same phone just
basically shrunk down and it's not
making any real sacrifices like sony has
said some other companies doing a mini
version where they remove some features
and make it a lower-end phone this is
what a lot of people have been asking
for it's a high-end phone and a compact
body I'm interested to see the price and
I'll keep you guys updated on that when
I figure that out so they go those are
the new Sony phones from the Sony booth
at CES 2014 keep it locked here for more
high quality CES 2014 coverage thanks
for watching I'll talk to you guys in
the next one peace
[Music]